you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
they're a danger to our universe you're
not going to take this away from me
you're struggling
to have
everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone welcome back everyone this is
going to be my new spider-man no way
home sinister 6 video i know you all
have questions about who the sixth
member of the team is because there are
only five that we see in the trailer
that we know of very misleading these
marvel trailers you can't totally trust
everything that you see
there was a recent clip that was
released that i think reveals what's
going on with that sixth member so we'll
break it all down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing a giveaway for
imax tickets all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber and leave all your
theories about who the sixth member of
the team is going to be on the video so
you've all probably seen the spiderman
no way home trailer a billion more times
since yesterday alone but there's still
been a lot of questions about what's
actually going on with the sinister six
in the movie in the sinister five of it
all because like i said we only see five
actual members of the team on screen in
the trailer footage they're very
prominent like they really want you to
think that this is the whole team but
it's not called the sinister five it's
called the sinister six and marvel
wouldn't roll this hard on sinister six
tropes spider-man versus sinister six
from the comics to not actually put a
sixth member of the team in the movie in
some way the way they're actually doing
the sinister six their actual story in
the movie is much twistier than you
would expect it's not meant to be a
straight-up spider-man vs the sinister
six kind of story but they're kind of
pitching it that way from the trailer
footage but thanks to a recent clip with
michael keaton it seems like he just
confirmed that he's going to be the
sixth member of the team as vulture
here's the clip of him talking about
getting ready to film new vulture scenes
he also talks a little bit about doing
new batman stuff briefly during this too
i'm shooting tomorrow i'm shooting you
shooting tomorrow yeah man what are you
shooting tomorrow some vulture stuff yo
your vulture tomorrow all right
i didn't go hey who else is what other
guys you're gonna be at you didn't say
that no because here's how bad it is
i'll show up and i'll go i'll be like
and then i'll go hey uh what point does
uh does spiderman show up or something
and they'll say
you know when does hulk come in i showed
up on one of the when i played vulture
which was really a fun character i gotta
say and uh
and i s they have to brief they have to
brief me
and i see it in their eyes they're going
uh so you know when um and then they'll
say when you did blah blah and then you
know your character tombs came in and he
did that thing remember because earlier
in spider-man and i'm going right right
i'm thinking
i have no idea who's who or why or where
even where i am i'm sure kevin feige is
probably going to be giving him a phone
call about that kevin feige been making
a lot of those kinds of phone calls to
actors and spider-man no way home
recently especially with jamie foxx kind
of confirming that there would be
multiple versions of spider-man in the
movie just yesterday after the trailer
came out thank you very much electro for
confirming that he kind of did that way
back when they announced his character
too last year like we've known for a
while now that there were going to be
multiple versions of spider-man but what
michael keaton is talking about in that
clip is how he's in two different
multiverse movies and it's just totally
confusing for him as an actor spiderman
no way home is a very spider-verse type
of multiverse movie he's also in the
morbius movie which i'll talk about in a
second because that's important for
what's happening with the vulture in
spiderman no way home especially after
what they did with venom in the venom
let them be carnage post credit scene
but keaton is also in the flash movie
playing a multiverse version of batman
so it's kind of the same concept so
that's why he was joking about the
producers of both of these movies the
spiderman no way home the marvel people
in the flash movie dc people having to
brief him on the continuity every single
time he goes into film new scenes for
these different movies the example he
gave was the spiderman no way home
producers having to remind him what
happened to vulture at the end of
spider-man homecoming and then during
the morbius movie and the big sinister
six arc in the movie is all about
testing spider-man's character that's
why he has this big moral conflict with
doctor strange in the movie spider-man
vs doctor strange is a fight over
morality if you've seen all the clips
recently of tom holland talking about
the movie he basically said his
spider-man will always try to save
people even the villains and doctor
strange is trying to send the sinister
six characters back to their original
universes which means sending them to
their deaths as both he and doctor
octopus tell him during the trailer so
that's why spider-man yoinks doctor
strange's box with the symbol of the
vashanti on it it's the same symbol
that's on all the sanctums and the
ibagamoto the box and the enchantment on
it is probably what doctor strange is
trying to use to send the sinister six
characters back so part of what's going
on in their arc all these sinister six
scenes in the movie is that spider-man
is trying to save them save the villains
but also trying to stop them from
destroying the main mcu reality like
they're trying to kill him mj and ned
leeds while he's trying to save them and
what does that remind you of it's
exactly the way they ended spider-man
homecoming with spider-man fighting the
vulture to stop him but also fighting to
save his life
time to go home pete
i'm trying to save you
so they're doing that again during
spiderman no way home wouldn't it make
sense to bring the vulture back again
for that vulture already did him a solid
in the spiderman homecoming post-credits
scene when scorpion teased that sinister
six team up vulture pretends to not know
his secret identity but mysterio kinda
threw that concept out the window still
though vulture owes spider-man his life
so i think the idea is what the wind up
showing us is that different versions of
spider-man in saving some of the
villains lives like toby maguire saving
dr octopus's life and spider-man 2 and
tom holland doing the same thing for
vulture karma comes back around and some
of those villains in the movie will help
spider-man defeat the other sinister six
characters without having to kill them
it also ties into the whole great power
great responsibility speech the classic
spider-man speech tom holland himself
actually quoted this at the recent event
where they revealed the trailer and we
have a responsibility to do the right
thing and help out our neighbor and look
after one another and that's exactly
what spider-man stands for
so with great power comes great
responsibility you do kind of wonder if
they're going to actually say that in
the movie just because they tried to
avoid doing the same spider-man tropes
in every single film like that's why
they avoided doing uncle ben during
spider-man homecoming but in my video
yesterday i talked about dr octopus's
arc during the movie where it actually
seems like based on some of the later
trailer footage it seems like he's
actually working with spider-man trying
to fight the other sinister six
characters because you see elektro
fighting him like blasting him with his
lightning out this window here a lot of
you probably also had this theory too
like doctor octopus actually being a
good character during the film because
of his arc during spider-man 2 in them
not wanting to trample on that if his
story in spider-man no way home is meant
to pick up right after the end of
spider-man 2 at the end of spider-man 2
he redeemed himself by trying to save
the city by pulling his reactor down
into the east river sacrificing his life
in the process but doctor strange's
spell and spider-man messing it up
effectively bringing him back to life by
yoinking him from across space-time so
even though you see a lot of scenes of
doctor octopus just giving spider-man
the business it does sound like at some
point he starts to help him like they
find some common ground after all the
joking about his name that is pretty
funny to see spider-man joking about his
name otto octavius but looking at all
the willem dafoe green goblin the
electro the sandman the lizard scenes it
just seems like some of the other
sinister six characters get backed into
a corner and they're fighting spider-man
thinking that they're fighting for their
lives so i think they're trying to do a
little more character development for
them in the movie like it's not just
about them wanting to kill spider-man
because they hate spider-man they're
actually fighting for their lives legit
like you can't send us home because
we're gonna die if we go home in the
whole idea that doctor strange is
basically giving them that you don't
have to go home but you definitely can't
stay here kind of speech like you're a
danger to the main mcu universe so you
cannot stay here but just based on the
way they in the trailer with that tag
scene just setting up doctor strange too
it seems like they do find some
temporary solution to this multiverse
problem but that solution just creates
larger problems for doctor strange with
reality crumbling around them that he'll
have to solve during doctor strange ii
multiverse of madness like yay we've
saved all the sinister six characters
lives in most of my friends lives and
successfully contained them but in doing
so they doom the main mcu universe quick
spoiler warning for the eternals movie
too this is kind of the way they ended
the eternals movie where they do wind up
saving the earth they saved the day but
in doing so they kind of doomed the
planet to judgment from the other
celestials and airshown the judge like
they kill a celestial and now they have
tiamet basically turned to stone in the
indian ocean just jutting out from earth
so big that you can see him from outer
space nick fury's one eye is probably
rolling into the back of his head up in
a space station just watching this all
play out but i think the idea with the
timeline is that this happens with the
eternals over on this side of the plant
like over in the indian ocean on the
other side of the earth right before
spider-man doctor strange in the
sinister six characters crack all of
reality like you see it crumbling around
them and the multiverse starts bleeding
into the main mcu universe in a really
big way so spider-man no way home
eternals and doctor strange 2 all kind
of overlap just a little bit but what
does the end of spider-man no way home
mean for the future of the sinister six
characters because if you guys have seen
the news the past couple of months sony
is basically working up to another new
spin-off sinister six franchise the way
that they were trying to do during the
andrew garfield amazing spider-man
movies so what they might wind up doing
at the end of spider-man no way home is
just dedicating a small scene at the end
to just let you know where they might
take that without necessarily pinning
themselves into a corner the same way
that the venom let there be carnage
scene only implied where their plot
might go like it sounds like venom is
going to be fighting spider-man in a
future movie but they didn't tell you
exactly how that's going to play out
everyone let me know in the comments
though what do you think about vulture
being the sixth member of the sinister
six team and also helping out spider-man
defeat them just like doctor octopus is
a member of the team but winds up
switching sides and helping spider-man
during the movie big reminder that
hawkeye episodes start next week they're
actually going to drop the first two
episodes on day one so i'll post my
videos for both of those next wednesday
when they release them i've got a couple
of the big spider-man videos that i'm
working on just leave all your requests
your big questions in the comments below
everyone click here to watch the
spider-man no way home trailer a billion
more times and click here to learn about
that mystery andrew garfield spider-man
scene thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys
in the next one
[Music]
you